The general good experience in a manner dangerous,
and that's why we have a system called the patriarchy took women might cost as a
bit about a great system to protect women from the ages of man called Patriarchy
and we threw it.
We throw it away because the colleges.
I think it's important to talk about Patriarchy because I feel that young 20
year old women need their own Illuminati to talk about their failures on what's
going on.
It's yeah,
it's like it's Illuminati for girls.
Conspiracy theory.
Patriarchy can ask for the set definition.
There isn't one.
Is that suspicious?
Same with racist.
There is one in the dictionary,
but that's not the accepted one.
Ask just any online feminist.
What does it mean?
There's no.
Well,
you can be wherever you can be like it's.
It's.
It means you're my ex boyfriend named Gary Click of mean girls is that
patriarchy are in a position of power.
That's the patriarchy,
but men have been in the workplace for hundreds of years more than women is that
there's a real problem with the idea that it should be caught up.
But what about when you hear this shit where somebody goes,
when people wonder where all the female comedians know who said that do to
people talking about it?
When?
When Louie got shellacked by that fucked up article,
people were saying that shit about,
you know what,
how come is that an equal number of female comedians to males?
Well,
because women are treated better in our society.
Yeah.
If there's an amount of female comedians,
you know,
women are being abused way more than ever because you don't get in this job from
a happy.
This job isn't about support.
It's you get last because you're fucked up.
So I hope there's not a lot of women in it that would mean they're being raped
more.
There's that.
But it is also just from a female perspective of a chick's funny.
It's harder because something happened to her.
They can't,
but they can't talk about certain things like,
no,
no man wants to see a woman on stage telling politic stories or politic jokes.
If it's funny,
I say that,
but it did create a lot of the daily show.
Maybe you're right,
maybe you.
But most people in the audience,
for the woman who started out harder,
I won't rule out anything if I'll take.
I won't say any premise has hackey just punchline.
So if your premise is airline fucking peanuts,
that's fine.
Tell me what your punchline is.
Maybe a punchline justifies it.
I don't,
I won't rule out any premise on the premises or hacky,
but people probably don't want to hear it.
But who,
you know,
it's like,
look,
if you can get people to listen to some shit that they basically don't want to
hear.
Like,
oh great,
this is for my use to do the black rooms I started.
So I totally agree with you.
I'm totally in agreement with you.
We're not talking about drinking caveman coffee.
We're not talking to you.
I feel wired is from that 270 milligrams.
How many did you have?
Like Gut.
Well I just started sipping wine,
but I'm like,
I feel like I get one that's empty.
Did you black out and suck down and just I just drank one.
What the fuck is this?
Nobody cares about those.
You like the use of like fungal.
It's not used that often.
It is in Jersey.
Go to the east coast.
Go to where those old school guineas landed on boats,
fucked each other on the rocks and made a bunch of them and they all stayed
there about fungal.
What's the.
What's the Italian Horn like?
If you're Italian,
you've attended one of those
shows.
You're a moron.
I don't know.
I don't know where it came from.
We all had them in high school though,
like if you had a gold chain with a horn,
like wow,
look at stylish.
Did Not know that thing existed.
It's called the scene that sperm before,
but that's probably what it is.
Cold sperm.
Little Horn or horn lit.
Sometimes abbreviated tacoma.
Isn't Italian amulet or talisman worn to protect against the evil eye
or Mala Chico and bad luck in general and historically to promote fertility and
virility.
That's the last thing we need is promote fertility and kids in high school
wearing those things.
So it is a sperm.
Yeah,
Neapolitan.
It's called.
Can we Cielo or variance thereof.
We talked by sperm.
That's crazy.
It is.
Just golden judges on your chest essentially.
Right?
The golden ges were protected from the evil one.
You gave me the blog,
but I still got my not off.
My Dad gave this to me.
They'll fucking evil eye over here.
Yeah.
What you're wearing it right where a pearl necklace with land too.
Yeah,
it's foul.
Foul little amulet.
Imagine they talk those kids into wearing golden ges around their neck and all
these years they thought,
hey,
that fucking evil.
I could suck my Dick.
How about that?
Hey,
I'm going to go out.
I got a good amount of gold chains.
I got a good solid fucking horn here.
Look at that.
Can't Catholic priest probably give them to me.
It looks like.
Come.
Yeah,
it doesn't even look like a horn.
What kind of fucking Horn is that?
Where it's round on top.
Like a,
like a sperm head towards aren't round at the top and it's rounded at the top.
It looks like it's swimming up stream to the guys.
Mass is going into your mouth.
If you go back,
go back to those pictures of different ones.
Is there anyone that has a flat top that looks like a fucking horn?
No.
All of them are rounded at the top.
Like ges,
those Italian horns.
They're all rounded at the top.
Like just.
This is insane.
I don't see any of them that.
Look,
that's not an Italian horn at six.
That's the wrong one.
That's got some like Gucci Shit.
Like someone,
some designer got ahold of it.
The new take on deal.
Italian horn.
It's all the rage.
Everyone wears it.
Yes.
I've got three on.
I can't believe people wear that shit.
They do.
They can't help themselves.
They grow up in those communities.
I did it too.
I wore.
You're around a bunch of east coast Italian people.
They're all wearing it.
You're all wearing it.
It's like God,
you got yet Tahlia and hon
and when I.
When I saw the guy that had it on,
he took.
I got.
Yeah.
I got and then kissed,
kissed the ges.
It's just my good luck.
God bless you.
God bless him.
What st be St Peter.
Right,
right.
I mean it's godly.
Which ones attached to it.
That's like weird,
like there's always affiliations like certain saints are attached to certain,
you know,
fucking ridiculous.
Wow.
This,
what year was this?
Dear God,
I don't remember.
I've been so much on whatever.
You're great for guys.
Been hitting the head as many as you.
Well,
I never had a concussion.
I will say that.
Well,
you must have never had a concussion.
But what is a concussion?
Concussion is like where they check.
Your pupils are not correctly.
None of it.
None of them.
No concussions at all.
All that hard sparring.
Nope.
Never.
I find that hard to believe this.
He never got hit with a shot that I didn't see coming.
And I think that's the difference.
Nope.
Besides one time in a huge fight where a dude hit me in the side of the head
with a brick and I saw it last second night at least rolled with it.
And that didn't give you a concussion?
He,
I,
he,
uh,
it was a huge.
It was hip hop night at the nightclub I was bouncing at.
Oh,
sounds like fun.
And and the Illinois gang and the Iowa gangbangers started going at it.
I tried breaking it up and they all attacked me,
right?
Jesus.
So that's when I.
Everybody was wearing,
it was wintertime,
so I was choking people.
A guy got me in a headlock and I was grabbing people by the lapels and I'd hit
my head in between his head and his head and I'd choke him unconscious.
I'd find a new coat.
And I was working my way backwards out the front door and finally snuck out of
the headlock,
put him in a rear choke,
went backwards out the door.
He went limp.
I dropped him.
And then as I turned to get out into the street,
because there was cops everywhere at that point,
there's dogs.
It's a snow storm.
Last second,
I see this coming at the side of my head.
Then I duck and it bounces off my head and this dude goes,
yeah,
like I was going to go down and I turned and I looked at him and rifle them with
the right hand and knocked him out.
And then the next thing you know,
there's just dogs diving into the crowd.
It was a good one.
And that was a fun one.
Dogs,
that's not good.
No.
Dogs Work Day work.
They work real well.
It's not good because they don't know who the fuck they're biting.
They might bite you.
They might buy the bad guys.
I mean,
who the fuck dogs don't know who the bouncer is.
Clear route real quick.
Fuck yeah,
they do.
Yeah.
After you've done it and you have.
You've done the workout and stuff.
Chilling.
Yeah.
You just feel loose and he feel amazing.
He's brilliant.
Every Wednesday morning and I don't want to go.
I'll fucking tell you the truth.
I'm driving down.
That's an hour away from me.
I'm thinking,
fuck this.
And then I get there and it's just.
It's just a very,
very special.
It's illegal.
Is Weed in England.
I'm not into it.
Me,
listen bro.
Take two solid hits and then go to yoga class.
Solid hits.
I'm behind in,
back in myself where I'm telling you it's not for the American.
We'll get ahold of some of this.
California orbit serious who hits and then go to a yoga class.
It's like you're on a journey.
You're like,
you get out of their hour and a half late.
It's perfect because an hour and a half into the sweating,
the pots worn off and you like to come back down and put in the middle of it.
You feel like the world's going to end any second now in the middle of the
class,
like there's no way this can be sustainable.
There's no way I'm not going to survive.
Did the whole way you think about everything that's going on and get on with
Joel will like a house on fire.
That's been mom,
my dad,
not me.
I can't do it.
I don't agree with me.
I love it for Yoga,
swollen,
my favorite things.
Ever take two hits and go to yoga class.
When you stone,
you can't not be on stone quick.
He just like,
Oh shit.
Right?
If it's well,
no,
there's no wearing off.
Quick Caffeine helps a little bit coffee.
Remember Jordan,
give me a drop economy so I'll be fine.
I like melody and we saw for for about six hours and I couldn't move and I'm
thinking I'm dead exam,
I'm donating time.
Last time I was here hired someone,
I add some cannabis oil and I was sat there watching TV and then I was like,
fuck,
you know those mine
got the remote control from the TV and this guy was gotten a little and it
turned him over and I went,
huh me fucking self.
And then I knew for no,
it's not for you.